hey guys Larry here with gamespot.com
and we are showcasing games done quick
where we're just having a bunch of
speedrunners playing games fast for your
viewing pleasure I am delighted to be
joined by fellow game spotters Danny
O'Dwyer oh and Jeremy Jane but most
importantly importantly we have a to do
in the house our speed runner and you
will be playing half-life 2 but a very
particular part this is highway 17 yes
so half-life 2 is a fun speedrun there's
a lot to it but it's also really long so
we're gonna do one part the coast part
of half-life 2 where you ride the buggy
around and it's exciting but more
importantly it's really cool to watch
and really fast it's a nice segment it's
like you've just had a hard day and
Raven home make your way to Nova
Prospekt it's like nice beautiful
scenery take your bug yes right that's
all you're gonna do you're gonna get in
the car and drive the whole way down I'm
gonna Beach cruise yeah I mean like yeah
we're in California we're used to these
Beach drives maybe a lot like that Irene
is a real place in California I grabbed
there almost every weekend it's kind of
Santa Cruz man [ __ ] have signs of
Monterey exactly it's a real Friday
you're just delusional and you really
like assess what half-life and I
describe there all the time pretending
all right let's pull it up and we'll get
ready so when you do give us a little
countdown timer and we'll start our
timer all right will do okay good
position actually had a so I have to
make sure I can lock my arm because I
have to keep it straight for quite about
a lot of the run am I too close
should I was lots of motions should be
good to go okay here we go three two one
go I'll just load the quick sale you
have here so all right the first thing I
see me do is not look forward oh I
choked
okay I hit a small piece of wood oh
you're not even using the buggy yeah no
there's like a really irritating
tutorial at the start there with the
buggy gets knocked over and everything
yeah and you have to fight the ant lines
and it's awful it's slow it's the game
which you can do the hop a lot faster
than the actual buggy because we are not
using the buggy there
things that you're supposed to use the
buggy for yeah right from the get-go
you're basically going to have to glitch
out the entire highway 17 segments so
that you can even get through it right
yes that's the familiar side as well
you're gonna go through about five of
those so this might go for now plus my
speed it's unnatural oh my goodness so
we can do it again that's the best part
of the game is right here with that
rocket fight and you're gonna help but
English dude just gonna skip over
I might die okay good okay so I have to
get back in bounds I'm kind of near a
bunch of invisible walls I'm taking a
lot of fall damage but that's okay I
believe in you
that'll be no TV sooo charger around
here some area something important to
know is where all the health kits are
how you to access I take a lot of fall
damage flying man I don't know how you
just don't like like how do you balance
not falling through death every time you
do one of those who skips every now and
then I followed my death yeah we all do
in this life oh my god I got dark dark
places in me studio so what we're doing
yeah if you keep rollin you can walk up
the hill it turns out it didn't even
it didn't even trigger the the the fight
so you don't even have to fight the
copter here I even play this game so
wrong for years
I literally complete this game every
November I've done every year since its
come out and he's ruining up for me you
gotta learn how to do this you can do
this actually I watched you do it once
and then I erased you this is magical oh
my gosh Jesus Christ I know what to say
to this it's a tough life - it's like
you guys are playing like this gradually
and I find that kind of weird
I remember this part I remember this
marmar we got five finish minutes more
of this beautiful magic remember
took them like six years to make
half-life 2 and then everyone complained
because they completed it in two hours
my back hopping yeah or is it puzzle
here you're gonna have to do this part
you're gonna have to hook up the thing
thing yeah yeah and I got to go
underground under bridge and all
definitely knowing that whole bridge
section you gotta hold back across the
bridge when you do the thing I saw this
part I'm expecting to go horribly wrong
and it won't right cool so right now
we're on a bridge I could there's a cool
strategy for this where I could blow
myself doing a train this is this is
more entertaining this is more inner - I
caught it myself I don't want to stay on
the stream alright I think I missed it
okay you like zooming so you can get
like perfect yeah horizontal alignment
there oh is that why your arm has to be
like locked when you do that just like
keep it perfectly straight Chappell be
painted put in like 2 seconds moving
quick is so here's a scary part there
are people out this that are way better
than me and going just weave it together
flawlessly it's amazing the cool thing
is these tricks like aren't that hard to
learn yeah like what I'm doing okay like
that's a threat nibbling the orange
eating on valuable seconds whoa so this
I don't know if all the work I'll
probably die yeah that's okay because
the same will put me in the air for a
little okay that's actually bad let's
see how this I'm gonna load which is a
little bit further back normally what
happens areas the sable lined up
perfectly for the launch
right before you launch you'll be on the
ground for a second and you can not
launch in the air if you don't want to
which is handy because getting that jump
is not super consistent because
sometimes you'll land up up above which
is where you want to go yeah sometimes
you'll land on the beach which is
not that great but least don't die
crease like perfect precision so there's
like a little bit of luck to it sort of
it's it there is some rng in this game
but not that much what makes it hard is
the fact that you you're just flying all
over the place and sometimes predictable
quite often it is not and that's where
getting scary this is mental
so what what are you doing you're like
using the mouse wheel yes so I have
bound a jump to mouse wheel up and the
mouse will all right screaming and
jumping backwards and just like yeah so
what the game is doing is it's trying to
I think I mouse a bit too much let's see
that's an incredible finger action man
you girls in your high school aside
famous be alright look at this it's like
ricochet it's like some dislike some
golf for somebody just knocking it off a
building I'm gonna back on have life
golf course the golf game that your oh
yeah desert golf there's a double
golfing ultimate desert golf edition
highway 17 stage oh my god yeah
rocketjump manipulating the fact that
there's actually no way to max out speed
going backwards yes so the game is
trying to slow me down when it pushes me
when I get speed but it does that by
pushing me backwards so if I'm looking
at a direction it's actually increasing
here yes and so I actually don't press
anything besides crouch and jump when
I'm doing it backwards like I have like
a side version where I'm strafing and
going backwards to try and trick the
game of this so does this work another
source engine games like um play like
csgo I'm in competitive games they patch
that [ __ ] I bet your day of defeat game
yeah but I think they defeat would be
amazing if you can fly over the bunkers
and come in from behind
um so this actually is a was part of
portal 2 and different source games
handle it differently
okay like the this was they're fixed to
original bunny-hopping
which there are old versions of
half-life 2 that Wow that said I made it
worse
yeah if they made it way faster it turns
out
there's a kind of a beautiful symmetry
with it as well because in the first
half life you get that Christ jump
module which is basically just crouching
and jumping yeah yeah that's kind of
what you're doing here and games like
that became such a true yeah well also a
half-life 1 for the speedran - like
that's a bunnyhop game
yeah I've seen people like doing this
luck kind of like jumping over the side
of it god you're able to do this with
such consistency see it and that's what
I'm saying is the scary part is there
are people that are way more consistent
than me like the community for this is
amazing
sourceruns.com is a good resource if you
want to see more just of any source game
and I'm Doc nak GOC nak ride that line I
want to see someone speedrun CS OH
so what I'm doing here that's kind of
making it harder as I'm sprinting the
the safe option is you just walk
casually because the sprint lets you
glide for a bit as you slow down she's
slowing dimensional think yeah so yeah
remember you get the antlion uh I
haven't what's called like the and that
thing is a long cutscene it's gone is he
got to talk to that vortigaunt forever
shut up
he's just down there like where's Gordon
he was on his way what we were talking
about patches earlier and how that can
actually affect your rug were there any
patches to this game yes and well it was
uh Oh actually yeah so they release a
new form of distribution on Steam just
turn on your flashlight so I'm okay
falling here directly sometimes I'll get
caught eight health is fine okay there's
a little bit of combat and like the only
guys I'll kill in this entire section
because they can screw up the next trick
but they're by a bunch of health packs
so I should be fine we're doing we do
this uneasy because on hard the fall
damage and self damage increases Wow
which means that like a lot of these
Falls wouldn't be possible I just died
and lines I'd love to say to my children
but I didn't get actually they still
follow me that
there's still my friends almost control
them yeah that's hilarious which is a
small problem he probably picked up this
I've decided you're a good person not so
bad I like the jumpy man I like to
imagine that you're just dropping in on
folks like some sort of like
extra-dimensional way there's a room and
you just appear out of the wall so this
is one of those things where it's gonna
look really good what I'm lining up with
but I but like after a while you just
know that Quan with the rock and the
ground but I mean that it was like a
small pebble oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my god I'm too high I'm too
high wow that was the way in the Nova
Prospekt all along you think all the
service personnel uses a service tunnel
Ashley okay although this trick is you
okay I'm astounded and scared excited
worried easy Jeremy are you watching
this easy okay
so the tricky part here is I can't move
my mouse a lot while it's loading
because it will still track that wow
really
so I have to stay steady oh yeah and I
need to make sure I don't go too high
like last time for Q slow you can kind
of bounce off all of these we'll do the
fast version because it takes about as
long as another attempt to a carissa
prop like to fly up there no I'm not
getting the speed Oh
so I'll just get this trick and you like
it wherever I land I'll just finish up
with that I go what you do this all day
yeah just fine okay
never talks Oh Kelly and this times
coming up right about now when the
zombie hits the water
well zombies are the water I'm going hit
the water
yeah
and time time can we bring out this is
probably one of the most amazing things
thank you so much studio for that what
was the end time on that I've never seen
anything like that
123 oh right 11 11 23 for half-life 2
highway 17 this is your robot um in the
studio thank you I don't know how to
explain this is this did you do this
with the speedrun did you break reality
can we get a mic on Brad yeah can you
see us
is this like that the movie ah don't
look at me
is this like that movie her is this
where is this where the future is going
I wish my mic would retail the best way
that I could have ever imagined where
are you or even the wall I want to see
the man behind the nothing at me
terrifying oh you guys like speedruns
then you're in luck because summer games
done quick 2015 is coming up is from
July 26th to August 1st they will be
running games continuously 24 hours a
day for your viewing pleasure with all
of all the money's going to Doctors
Without Borders and you can check it out
then so be sure to do that Brad will be
your house and kill you if you don't in
his robot suit lost some weight
this is the first Terminator prototype
spoken doing mic talk into the mic
goddammit
I didn't know that existed into rub rub
we've learned a lot about life and
technology today folks from robot iPads
that can walk around on their own no
creeped out right now nothing that I
know about the world is is real nothing
is sacred anymore wherever he goes I
wish someone got to be little buddies
crashing it's just driving into a ps4
box repeatedly use me told her I really
happening but that's in it for all of us
here at GameSpot thanks for watching our
games done quick speedrun again if you
are interested in speedruns do check out
summer games done quick or the games
done quick people they have their own
Twitter and they're awesome to follow
the great group of guys and you should
check them out so that's it for us thank
you to jeremy Jane again yeah Dwyer
studio romscout and rajulun we also have
some people in the back Jake Dan Eric
Kay Josh aw thank you guys so much for
putting this together and thank you guys
for watching we will see you next time
bye